a computer by the name of Eugene because
what other name would a computer have
passed the Turing test which basically
means it simulated humored human
conversation as a thirteen-year-old boy
we've got a little more info for you the
Turing test which tests artificial
intelligence was introduced by Alan
Turing in 1950 he predicted that
computers would one day be able to be
programmed to acquire abilities rivaling
human intelligence we're pretty much
right there a person engages in a
text-based conversation with another
person and a computer and must determine
which is which if they're unable to do
so the computer is deemed to have passed
it requires 30 percent of human
interrogators to be duped during
five-minute keyboard conversations so I
feel like we've all before we get into
the specifics of this feel like we've
all had these experiences with these
computers like if you go on to like Time
Warner chat to try to find something out
and you literally can't tell if you're
talking to so does this surprise you
that this test has been what I have been
what I've been reading about this online
is that it this is a hoax that this guy
no yeah this guy at Reading University
is apparently infamous for these sort of
things I think he claimed to be the
first human to be infected with a
computer virus and that apparently a lot
of people have been sort of gullibly
kind of reporting this story but it's
not true so it seemed it seems like it's
half true that apparently this did it
did actually pass but there's some
questions about his methodology so I
don't want to get too focused on that
just more the broader broader idea by
the way real quick about Alan Turing he
was persecuted for homosexuality and
after he was convicted in 1952 he was
chemically castrated a little something
there and and after winning world war 2
thanks very much yeah no no he's one of
the great game arters of history and
actually doesn't be a movie about him
starring Benedict Cumberbatch coming out
this year really hopefully at that and I
think a stamp will get him his due I
think but yeah no Alan Turing is a what
is it you're really smart gay people
because the guy from a beautiful mind
also although the movie made it seem
like it wasn't he gay uh yeah we're
you know smarter gay guys are good with
numbers I don't okay so going back to
this without getting too much into the
to the specifics of the test because
it's a little unclear as I said when are
the robots taking over as I somehow
asked on this show every week what's
interesting is that Ray Kurzweil
particularly this would happen by 2029
obviously a lot sooner than I think that
well no I mean you know you made Chris
well that like the 50s guy you know from
outer space the old TV psychic I think
we need to redefine how we how we define
artificial intelligence you know I mean
obviously this is a test that was
devised in 1950 so a lot of those ideas
you know whenever they tried to predict
the future in the 50s it ends up looking
ludicrous
well yeah but uh you know I think it's
um what's interesting is that this
device what they told the patent the
jury panel that it was a 13 year old boy
in English was not his first language
automatic cranium is you quickly yeah
and and so I don't think it's a surprise
that that he won you know and but it was
hardly a supercomputer was an algorithm
that was designed to be a chatbot and by
the way this isn't even the first time
that happened robot in 2011 called a
clever bot that did this in India
so again when do the robots take over I
want it I want a date I think it's
neck-and-neck do the robots take over
before or after we render the earth
uninhabitable to humanity you're gonna
be a great time yeah that's I think you
know to who's gonna get there first I
don't know yeah do you guys think that
maybe some of this like I always talk
about it as if the robots are a takeover
we did a thing on Google cars last week
they won't even have steering wheels so
you'll be trapped in your cars to be
able to hack into them and then we're
all walking around with these devices so
they can watch us and listen to us about
am I just totally alarmist on this and
that being said I still do all this
stuff and I love it I think it's so cool
and I love all the movies about it
but is that just purely alarmist that
mean I think I think it's great I think
the idea of having driverless cars he
could potentially save us from having
lots of accidents I mean there was a
huge accident in the news over the
weekend about a truck driver who hadn't
slept for 24 hours and caused that huge
pileup and Melanie Moore
right um you know Google is now they're
offering like you know cloud storage for
autism research which is supposed to be
amazing so I'm definitely like bullish
on the future I think that like
technology has amazing things to offer
and you know it's it's it just gets sort
of out of hand when the media takes
something that's not really a story and
you know blows it out of proportion the
way they did with this supercomputer but
I do think that at the end of the day
we're heading in the right direction
yeah yeah you know III wish Google would
stop censoring the Chinese Internet but
they are obviously maybe making a lot of
cool things happen and I'm not I I don't
worry so much about what we're what
we're surrendering the technology as
much as I'm not kidding I really wonder
if if if Skynet is gonna take over if
they're gonna beat us to destroying the
ozone layer and you know like making
them all the ice caps melt right or as
in what happens in the Terminator movies
and like wall-e that they'll have to
enslave us because we're the ones that
are destroying the earth and it'll be
against their written orders their laws
and then they'll have to turn on us I
for one welcome our new robot overlords